hey everyone this is Stephen waddrop
with collider and I am thrilled to be
here with butcher's Crossing at the
Toronto International Film Festival
gentlemen I want to first start by
saying congratulations for being part of
Tiff best Festival uh it's my favorite
and I really want to say thank you for
making this film specifically because
the story of our our history needs the
story of what happened to the Buffalo
and that period of time is so important
that we talk about to try to make it so
we can fix our own mistakes
um okay but really if it's all right I'd
like to start with you
um what was it about the material that
said I need to turn this into a feature
you know I I read the book a long time
ago and and it kind of instantly hit a
nerve spiritually for me because I uh
you know connected with a lot of the
themes in the book you know the themes
of you know the search for meaning and
understanding the world you know uh
wanted Adventure kind of out into the
Wilderness uh
also the the idea of kind of what is the
the nature of ambition and sort of how
it can be you know a powerful positive
force but also incredibly destructive
um and I also kind of wanted to you know
I was really taken by the you know
environmental message and sort of how
what is the cause of this Devastation uh
to the planet you know what is the cause
we all know what's happening it happens
over and over but what is the cause it's
it's ambition it's sort of
you know not just greed but sort of this
desire to
you know this short-sighted you know
kind of ambitious desire and and sort of
tackling that cause I wanted to uh look
at all those things and examine it in
this kind of amazing landscape
Nick I'm curious obviously I know you
were offered a lot of scripts and people
want to work with you what was it about
Miller and this project specifically
that said I need to do this well much in
the same vein as what Gabe just said I I
read the book and
there were other characters and other
great books from American literature uh
wolf Larson from the Sea Wolf Jack
London uh Captain Ahab Herman Melville I
actually was invited by Ron Howard to
play wolf Larson in the sea wolf and
then he went made the gridge instead but
that character resonated with me there's
an intelligence to the character and
there's also this bloodlust and ambition
to the character and I always wanted to
play something like that to explore that
condition
when Gabe offered me Miller in butcher's
Crossing I thought I could get close to
something like that the story resonates
for me because it is curious this this
this human nature that exists in all of
us we there's two dogs you have a which
dog do you feed the good dog or the bad
dog the one that's the strongest is the
one that you feed the most and Miller is
feeding the wrong dog and this is the
this is the dog that brought a species
to near Extinction which was uh actually
the Life Source and the spiritual life
source for the Native American people so
there was this element of genocide on
two fronts you kill the Life Source the
Buffalo you kill the people and that was
something that as atrocious as it is I
thought we need to hold a mirror up to
that and reflect that so it doesn't keep
happening well we think twice about
these mistakes and yet if we look around
ourselves today it's still happening
it's happening with the trees it's
happening with the the you know tuna
fish it's happening with the dolphin
it's just happening and we have to look
at that I I that's one of the reasons
why I'm so happy you guys are here to
talk about the film because it does it's
so shameful that this happened in the
1860s and the late 1800s and yet you
look around our planet right now it's
like we haven't learned a effing thing
it's just it's very it's it sucks it's
shark fin soup man it's shark fin soup
100 I I have to ask you what was it like
listen you're an up-and-coming actor but
this is Nick Cage
uh and I just have to know what was it
like for you when you found out you were
going to work with Nick and what was it
like the night before the first day of
filming for you
um just because I'm sure you're a fan
yeah that is very true and
I I
felt an immense honor and excitement
knowing that that I was gonna get to be
a scene partner with one of my favorite
actors ever
um
and I I think there's a there's a
similar the thing that connected is
getting to watch his great work for so
long without talking around here but but
but
there's a creativity
um as a as a young audience member that
that inspired me to want to act so then
to be able to
to play together and and be in the room
with them finding choices that that that
I couldn't predict
um thanks to the joy of working with
them was was unbelievable the night
before I was nervous and I was excited
it was that kind of classic blend
um but but I also I think underneath all
those nerves felt uh uh
a need and a knowledge that that
um it was going to be a really special
experience is there anything that for
for I'm assuming everyone loves learns
on every project you make
um was there anything that you took away
specifically from working with Nick
um that you're going to take with you to
future endeavors yeah I I I think it's
sometimes hard to put exactly into words
the lessons that
um
you get but but
um
it's it's it's more of a of a
I get two things right one would be the
the ineffable sort of practice of
finding we call this or the Jazz of the
scene the thing that that that you can't
plan that that happens when you you
prepare prepare prepare but then you
tune in and let yourself go and find
what the the true Rhythm of the scene
needs to be
um and then the other thing would be the
great joy of laughter in between all of
it even if you're doing a very intense
story like this
it's it's important to be able to joke
and and and laugh and so I think those
two things together
change my life and I'll carry with me
always
well no absolutely I mean he said it's
so articulately and beautifully that's
exactly how I feel you know all actors
are my brothers and sisters so as soon
as we we meet
um it doesn't matter how many movies you
made or how a few movies you made
there's a familial connection right off
the bat and I think that's understood
it's implicit there's a flow but what he
just said about the Jazz that's so
important to me it's like let's we're
prepared but let's be so prepared we can
get off preparation and go into these
happy accidents that can't occur because
sometimes those are the that's the goal
that we can find that the spark that
came out of the Collision the collider
Collision the Jazz you know and the
laughter is important I learned that
especially when I was doing says he's
bringing out the debt I would go on
ride-alongs with paramedics and they all
had this Gallows humor it's like well
why but I realize every day they're
seeing things like chest cracks gunshots
and they're they're going to get burnt
out if they don't find little moments in
their daytime to decompress so when Fred
and I were going these crummy little
corners of our imaginations to find
these guys it was important that we
could step aside and just decompress
with a couple of jokes and then get back
in and get to that crummy corner of our
minds again you know 100
um Erwin I wanted to ask you real fast I
have a million questions but one of the
things I want to thank you for your work
in and your tribe's work in the Pres
preserving Buffalo bringing them back
um and I wanted to know for people that
are watching can you sort of mention if
someone wanted to help if wanted to be
involved what can they do to assist yeah
um well at first off I just wanted to
say you know it was real good uh and
exactly what Nick talked about of the
you know hunting the animals to the new
Extinction and um you know all the
wrongdoing there
so what I would like to see you know
that we would come forward from the
movie is that exactly that people would
come and want to help
the tribes and I work with a an
organization that is the 76 tribes and
restoring Buffalo back to any country
and the biggest thing is that they have
is
um
you know infrastructure for tribes a lot
of tribes are a real Strat for dollars
and but yet they're trying to bring back
a big part of their culture that was was
lost and taken away so in any way that
that people would be able to to help
those tribes and and we do work with a
lot of other organizations that are
really trying you know to give
tribes you know a hand in restoring
Buffalo back to their lands so
um just by this movie getting the story
out there the devastation
um that was that happened to the Indian
people and buffalo
um and getting that realization that we
need to help in some way to help them
restore you know these animals back to
to their lands in any way that they
could would be good
and the fact that Urban allowed us into
these deeply sacred places it's
blackfeet nation is a Sovereign Nation
we went to places that most people don't
get to see and it was powerful and
magical but after everything that's
happened that he would allow us to come
in and film there and help guide us and
and teach us is just such a beautiful
exchange and and thank you for that
Urban yes thank you Gabe can you talk a
little bit every movie is a challenge
um it's a miracle that anything is made
uh can you talk about how difficult was
it to get this off the ground and get
the financing to be able to tell this
story was it like a crazy Boulder
pushing up the hill or was it um we'll
talk a little bit about that yeah it was
a you know
um you know making any any film is is
really challenging this in particular
the you know I don't know if it was the
genre the the
you know the the material was just you
know
for some reason difficult to get made it
took me you know 10 years to to just you
know get the financing for this uh film
and
it was and then you know once we you
know figured that out it it it you know
I found out kind of really close to
shooting
that you know we that we in order to
in order to make this movie we're gonna
have to shoot it in 19 days and uh
you know for this kind of movie it's
sort of sweeping and epic and you know
really you know a lot of locations
animals Buffalo herds you know it's just
uh you know mind-boggling you know to to
to achieve that I just want to interrupt
and say I honestly cannot believe you
made this movie in 19 days because I've
seen the movie I I really I commend you
well I appreciate that no but it's
because of you know everybody involved
the producers the actors because you
know you
you have to be incredibly precise and
prepared and you know
and just basically nail it you don't
have many shots at the plate you know so
everybody did a tremendous job and it
was the hardest thing I've ever done I
think I've done a lot of things this is
the hardest thing I've ever done
uh Nick if you don't mind I'm curious
how did you did you two decide on
Miller's look how did you decide on the
way Miller was going to look I have a
two-parter but let's start with that
well it was with Gabe I mean he was the
one well I guess he hails from Chicago
and we all know the the the phenomenon
and the dynamic force and the ambition
and the need to win of Michael Jordan
and um
he was saying think about that and I was
like why don't you why don't you shave
your head and and have that you know
think about that uh that for
ferociousness on the court that he has
that he has to win at all costs and I so
I did think about it and then I I went
ahead and said okay and then I thought
about because of the Conrad Heart of
Darkness element which is a similar kind
of Curts is a similar kind of
uh force of nature to Miller I've
thought of you know francis's movie
Apocalypse Now and what Brando looked
like but it was kind of a a combination
of Jordan Brando
so can I comment about Jordan so what I
you know I think you know Michael Jordan
you know greatest athlete ever but
there there is kind of a and he he'll
say it himself you know a sort of dark
side to Michael Jordan you know I think
that he
he would say that he you know nobody can
get in his way you know he would say
things to his teammates that were you
know and push them to the limits and do
you know a lot of people say you know
it's kind of a dark guy you know and
then intensity so I think that there is
kind of a Darkness
to that kind of intensity and ambition
you know and I always
felt that from him and that's why I kind
of wanted
to talk to him and protect Nick
particularly about Michael Jordan
um my other thing about Miller is I was
curious as I was watching it did you
decide what his backstory was in terms
of his motivation that he needed to you
know what I mean because he was
obsessive in terms of going after the
buffalo
Steve the thing is the the book itself
the reason why I like making movies that
are based on literature is that there's
a blueprint that's in existence it helps
so much to have that right off the
get-go if I need to find a way back to
the core I read the book again and then
it stimulates the imagination the
ambition
of this character there's the obvious
capitalistic I need to have a big score
a big win come in with the biggest fish
the biggest Marlin win the jackpot you
know have all the Buffalo pelts and have
the biggest prize and then there's the
implicit
I you know in my own mind I was thinking
this
Miller is an agent of genocide it's not
in the script it's not on on camera but
in the head the subtext he was actively
going after the people you kill off the
Life Source you kill off the people he
is the worst kind of person in that
Dynamic a villain but with any villain
you can't think of it in terms of
villain you have to find whatever
twisted sick philosophy of that person
that human nature internally is so you
can play it sincerely you can play it
organically and you're not faking it in
other words you have to go to that
crummy place in your imagination uh Gabe
one of the things I found and I have to
wrap very soon um but one of the things
I found very powerful was your use of
vintage photographs in the movie um at
the beginning and at the end I don't
want to be specific with what is in the
photographs
um but can you talk about your decision
as a filmmaker to include those yeah I
mean it's you know this is a a story
that actually happened and it it is sort
of based on you know history you know
it's not necessarily
you know a non-fictional film but it's
based on what happened in history and I
wanted the audience to understand that
and feel that these are events that
actually were happening to the Buffalo
it's what it's what happened based on a
lot of accounts that I read from the
time and clearly the Buffalo went from
you know 60 million to you know 300 you
know so
I wanted the audience to understand the
reality
because no one's ever seen you know a
story like this you know and I don't
think they really teach
this in schools and sort of you know
it's a it's an important historical
uh
moment imagine if the animal was gone
was extinct it's amazing what Irvin has
done bringing it back you know I think
about the Tasmanian Tiger I think about
the dodo bird I mean these were all
animals that were clubbed to death or or
shot you know and this this if that
beautiful animal was gone for our
children never to see again wouldn't
that be heartbreaking it's like the
woolly mammoth you know it's the last of
the Ice Age you know yeah I actually I
have a tough time with with animal
cruelty and I will admit that your film
it it's very powerful because I had a
really tough time with it you know what
I mean it's it's hard you know you know
I just like to say you know all of the
the past history of of
um of the killing I guess of the Buffalo
um but even today in this day and age we
as a tribes in the organization that
we're going forward and restoring
Buffalo back we still run into a lot of
resistance a lot of it a lot of racism a
lot of discrimination
against the Buffalo and the people we
still run into that so the biggest thing
too that we would need help in is to get
over that get over that that hump that
it's an everyday thing
um even like us today we have a bill our
organization that are trying to get past
just to help us
um restore Buffalo and uh and there's
big resistance to that so even in this
day and age it's like they still want to
get rid of them yeah that's one of the
reasons I'm so happy you made the film
and while you guys are so happy in the
studio I just have one last question uh
if you don't mind
um did you come up with a reason because
as I'm watching the film I kept on
wondering why you know uh why the
character wouldn't why he didn't stand
up to Miller or be more assertive did
you come up with a reason or was it sort
of like he was enchanted I mean what
what was your Mo what was your thinking
I I see it as a pretty broken love story
in some ways it it's it's that
um thing when
you've realized you've you've pined your
hopes on the wrong hero basically who's
as Victor said not not a hero in these
ways a villain in these ways but but
that that there's this sense of
at first
personal
spiritual growth through someone and
then you realize
um that your naivete has led you
somewhere that you're trapped in and you
don't and you don't know how you were so
oblivious and you don't know how you got
there
um and I think there's a line that
McDonald's has near in the film and in
the book near the end where about you
know everyone I'm
sort of crudely paraphrasing but but the
idea being that like
um by the time you learn something it
it's too late you've you've already
created
the suffering or wasted your life or or
messed up in all these ways and I think
that's one of the great Pains of
uh our history and and and in a much
smaller way the sort of cipherness of
will Andrews which is we've taken way
too long to learn this lesson
um and we have to
truly understand it now because I don't
think we can afford any more time wasted
that happens all the time you know the
the older folk throwing the 17 year olds
to the front line you can't have a
martini you can go kill somebody at War
I mean that kind of it's amazing the old
folks are just sitting there safely in
their little rooms and all the youth are
being slaughtered that's how it goes you
know and because they are innocent and
they are naive they want to believe in a
a higher goal and they realize they've
been taken they've been shamed and in
every industry Ever every person goes
through this kind of store in their life
so I mean whether it's Buffalo yeah I I
really really for everyone watching I
really do hope that you tune in for this
and watch it's a very it I'm very very
happy you guys made the film
and I want to say a sincere thank you
for coming into our studio today to talk
about it
um thank you thank you thanks for having
me